starting shortly please take
your seats thank you. See if
you will. I know it's always
like old home week to see your
friends we're going to ask that
we want to begin on time you
know everyone has a very busy
schedule. We'll make sure that
we that everyone has an
opportunity to be heard- we've
got some important individuals
here tonight to. Share with you
important information and
hopefully we'll hear some good
things and make recommendations
and a host of things will
happen. To our soul want to be
timely. And respectful of your
time because I know you all
students and somebody has an
exam in the morning- if it's if
it's true to form- so I wanted
to take this opportunity up. As
we begin I want to thank the UC
Berkeley's. AS UC's governing
body. Best of vasha and
Maureen. And all the hard
working students and student
organizations that have helped
to make this hearing happen. In
addition I'd like to thank the
chancellor Carol Chris who's
here and her staff. For
allowing me to hold the
assembly select committee on
campus climate here UC
Berkeley. I am assembly member
Shirley Weber I represent the
seventy ninth assembly district
which is in San Diego. I'm one
of the senior members of the
California State Assembly. I
not only cheer the budget on
public safety. But also serve
on the Education higher it
committee of the banking and
finance committee- as well as
elections and redistricting
committees- I'm very honored to
be here today- it with my
colleagues of. Who's also here
with us today. Just walked in
assembly member wicks- good to
have her here this is her
districts I want to thank her
for allowing me. To peep into
her district tonight. And to
have this hearing here- I also
want to stay in appreciation to
the panelist. Who took the time
from their busy busy schedule
today to show important
information. About important
issues occurring on college and
university campuses. And I
wanna thank them for coming to
this this hearing. This evening
after a long day of work and
activity. I want take his time
not to introduce UC Berkeley's
chancellor Carol Chris Ste
Christ. Who I understand has
left a meeting to join us. And
give welcome remarks- she will
be here through the student
Panama understanding. And up so
she's going to give her opening
remarks now and then we will
hear from- allow assemblymember
wicks and other committee
members- to also a have speak
after I have given you some
opening remarks but I want to
respect chancellor crisis. A
time and give her an
opportunity to give you welcome
to this campus thank you. Thank
you assemblymember Weber. Hi
good evening everyone and
welcome to UC Berkeley I'm so
pleased to have assembly member
Shirley Weber here at UC
Berkeley for this hearing. I
want to personally thank her
for her leadership. On this
important topic of campus
climate. The work of the select
committee on campus climate
continues to be of great value.
Giving voice to our students
and holding colleges and
universities accountable. In
building support of an
inclusive campus environments.
I also want to welcome our
local assembly member Buffy
wicks Buffy is in a great
champion for our campus and for
higher education. Entities more
broadly and her short time in
the assembly and we greatly
appreciate her support thank
you for being here. Our vice
chancellor of equity inclusion
Oscar to bone. Will provide an
update on the steps that we've
been taking to approve our
campus climate later in this
hearing. Although I believe
that we are making progress on
these issues. Must also
acknowledge that many
challenges persist after years
of systemic marginal Asian.
We've got your- thing and
respectful campus climate. And
bill isn't in France
foundation. For the realization
of our values of academic
excellence it accepts. However.
On staff to divert every sort
cannot be fully realized when
individuals are marginalized
due to their origins outlook
store orientations it's our
responsibility to prepare our
students to fully engage in a
world defined by difference and
diversity and to provide a safe
and welcoming community for all.
Last year we launched a
comprehensive undergraduate
student diversity project at
Berkeley. The projects goal was
to provide the analysis
necessary both to expand
diversity within the student
body and to improve the campus
experience for those groups and
communities that have
historically been under
represented or marginalized in
higher education. The effort
yielded a set of
recommendations the challenge
us to reexamine arm to just to
young people and their families
and communities as well as our
overall intentions process sees
alignment and culture. The
recommendations also make it
clear that we must strive for
equity of experience for every
student our campus. Builder
torture of belonging and
identify ways to highlight
those from under represented
and marginalized groups as
contributors and co
constructors of our university.
These efforts which price per
chancellor to bone will talk
about in more detail. Are
necessary for us to remain a
top teaching and research
institution. An essential for
us to truly meet our
universities public mandate.
Thank you again for being here
today. Doctor Weber I sincerely
appreciate your interest in
bringing this dialogue to the
campus so that we can hear from
our students and continue to
improve our efforts in making
our communities a safe and
welcoming as possible so that
our students can thrive. Thank
you thank you- want to thank
the chancellor for coming for
being here and the weed I know
we've been trying to get to
Berkeley for the last five
years and somehow another is
always been something going on
or something that intervenes
and prevents us for coming so
we were determined this year to
do that. This come this
commission of this select
committee is one of the oldest
select committees in the
assembly that is still
functioning. Created in two
thousand fourteen. This marks
the fifth year of the select
committee on campus climate.
I'm and I Xin is to ensure that
the state's college campuses
are safe welcoming environment
for all students. Five you
traveled up and down the state
of California hosting hearings
at different colleges.
Listening to diversity experts
civil rights groups and
students to gain insight and
generate policy recommendations
to improve the campus climate.
Of the state's community
colleges cal state university
and the UC system's. We've
covered a range of topics from
campus sexual assault and
violence to hunger and
homelessness among college
students. And we have a lot
more to explore. This committee
has authored numerous pieces of
legislation that have passed
and have made a difference
across the campus is
particularly. In the area of
homelessness and food in
securities. Higher education
for many of our young people
learn and examine the world in
which we it happen. In the near
future students from the UCC
issues in the community
colleges will be setting the
climate. Not only for their
campuses but for the entire
state of California. It was
interesting when we began this-
this this- committee this
hearing the select committee. I
was asked to chair the
committee because- at the time
of those are speaker Mister pet
issues now the chair of the
regions- we had an incident at
San Jose state. And we he was
greatly concerned that we did
not have proper response to
instead. He looked around and
he decided that I would. Yeah
he called me actually doing one
of a to the holiday break. And
asked me to chair of this
committee of the select
committee and he said because
he looked around and he
realized that of all the
members on the assembly. And
the Senate that I was one we
have the longest record in
higher education having been a
professor at San Diego state
forty years. And a chair of a
department on and off of
probably thirty years that I
can understood the campus
climate the campus community.
And could probably pull
together some things that were
important in addressing it. Of
the legislature in I'd not only
see that this is not just a
discussion of the day. But in
investment in tomorrow. When we
first began this someone said
well the problem reason we were
having at at that particular
time was because- students come
from so many places across the
state. And they meet at our
university campuses and so it
almost looks like so therefore
the campus climate keeps
changing because of the
students that of the year. My
response was that our campuses
are not. Just are not
thermostats I mean they're not
the monitors they don't just
measure the climate they
determine the climate we have
thermostats. And we gonna so
where students come from we
have to have a set of standards
that we- expect for every
student on this campus at the
parents who send their children
to us. Should expect a campus
that we control. That will
provide safe. And welcoming
experiences for every student
regardless of where they came
from. And so we're not here
just to measure what's
happening we're here to talk
about how do we determine. The
kind of the environment and
spirit that needs to be on
every campus- as we continue to
grow. As a system- would be a
become then will become
increasingly diverse. I student
needs. To feel safe when I
campus and knowledgeable about
campus procedures policies and
services. This select committee
as I said was formed in
nineteen in twenty fourteen.
Because of what was happening
at San Jose. In that could have
happened on any campus at that
particular time. And that it
was not fostering and building
a positive campus climate.
Unfortunately symbols of hate
offensive hate speech in acts
of intimidation have continued
to be on a steady incline in
the last four years. According
to the data released by the
anti defamation league. There
has been a 77% increase across
the nation of white supremacist
propaganda distribution on
college campuses. For twenty
eighteen nineteen the academic
year California have the most
incidents with fifty eight
incidents of extremist
propaganda. Followed by
Kentucky with twenty two in
Oklahoma with nineteen. I think
that shocks most. Because
normally people think of
California. As this place of
tremendous diversity liberal
thinking of people working
together because that's the
image that we have. But as we
have begun to delve deeper into
the activities that happen in
California- we realize that
this is a place that has
tremendous issues of race. And
gender- and religion across the
board in terms of division
that's the year. Some of you
are familiar with AB three nine
to our rates are bill dealing
with police up- use of force
and one of the driving forces
was a California has the
highest number. Of deaths of
done by police are still on
armed individuals in the nation
that was shocking to. Because
we- think that it's an out
family or Mississippi but it
was in California. And so
there's some things California
to come and grapple with and we
have the leaders. Taking the
charge of changing the elements
that it. The again the math is
right. White premises language
to explicitly racist images and
will. Often include a
recruitment element and
frequently expects minority
including people Muslims
nonwhite immigrants in the LGBT
community. Oftentimes college
campuses in their community
should be places for learning
and growing and the future and
not close minded racism and
hate Phil rhetoric from the
past. But races incidents are
not limited to the all right
segment we continue to see lack
of cultural competency within
our general campus cult
culture. Nooses students in
black face and this table
called cultural appropriate
appropriations a continue to be
seen frequently throughout our
California campuses- I'm not a
big football fan but last night
I once again saw the black cat.
Run across the feel during the-
I guess it was the Dallas
Cowboys game and some people
all that's not important but it
reached back of. Jackie
Robinson in the nineteen
forties when they put a black
cat on the baseball field to
intimidate him- and for people
may not see it happens once
again the thinking of those who
would do such an act. That is
the episode reminds us of
something never. Seem to dial.
Up we see this by this incident
and at some. Of the new series
the distasteful a black face
the culture appropriate in an
activities that occur. We see
the response of these
appropriate incidents as just
as important as the work being
done to prevent these incidents
from occurring. The leadership
of our institutions of higher
learning and their diversity
composition is also critical to
the progress of campus climate.
I know we could not completely
solve all campus climate
incidents the wealth
California. But we can surely
work to lower the frequency of
the numbers of these campus
climate incidents and we surely
can raise our level of
intolerance. It is our hope
that these hearings provide
greater insight to discover
what's working what's not how
we can improve and if possible
implement and standardize some
of the best practices. I want
to say up front that this is
not a meeting this nine two
lamb passed any particular
campus law of that's that's in
the state. However the
objective. Of this hearing is
to disclose what's occurring on
campus. Campus how these
incidents are being handle and
to find solutions to improve
outcomes. Simply because we're
here at Berkeley doesn't mean
Berkeley has more problems than
UC San Diego I can tell you it
doesn't- but we're here because
we want to make the hearings
acceptable to people throughout
the state. And to hear from all
the various campuses as to what
they're doing to address these
issues- today as a chance to
learn about the work being done
naturally around campus
climate. Here from student
voices and explore how
California's higher education
segments are responding to and
combating the rise of hate. We
also have a chance to follow up
in here from the UC see issues
in the community colleges about
the progress they've made one
their comedic on the campuses.
And committees formulated
policy recommendations from
twenty fourteen to we also is a
check up to see what we have
done. In the last five years-
at this time I want to give an
opportunity for my- colleagues
to. Make comments assembly
member wicks who is from this
area. And I welcome. And given
opportunity to give you see
welcome. I don't think Baker
costs such a rock I now sorry.
Hi everyone I just wanted to
come in welcome everyone to
this conversation and welcome
my colleague Dr Shirley Weber
at to the gorgeous wonderful UC
Berkeley thank you for coming
to visit I want to thank the UC
for hosting this and thank the
chancellor for- for being here
you know- I started Weber
described we've seen an
increase in white supremacist
propaganda. We've seen an
increase in hate crimes across
this country you look at-
information from the anti
defamation league to the
Southern Poverty Law Center to
the ACLU organizations that are
dedicated to tracking and
combating the stuff and- now
more than ever any this
conversation. You know we've
seen this increase and frankly.
Our races president gives
license to it. You know and so
that makes it incumbent upon
the rest of us at all levels of
government in this state and
across this country and those
of you in this room to actively
call it out. And push back on
it and take action on this it's
I think were in a really
critical moment right now in
our nation's history. On this
issue in particular. Ought to
this right and- what these
types of visits is due- but
it's- more important now than
ever and so how do we address
it. You know it's- up shining a
spotlight on it it's a having
public forms it's having the
dialogue around it. And then
it's about taking action and
what we're really talking about
here is someone comfortable
truth. That we really need to
look in the mirror as society.
And talk about these
uncomfortable truths and I will
say. And there's no one more
better equipped in the state
legislature. To drive the
conversation about
uncomfortable truths. The
doctor show it was Shirley
Weber. And you know I've been
in the legislature for a year
now and we have some great
colleagues there some very
smart people. Who work
incredibly hard- but watching
hurt navigate. The bill around
police use of force- it was
pretty amazing and that was
about on. Double truths. We
give Shirley Weber around
applause for that. And so
you're all good hands here with
her leadership on the
conversation but I also want to
say- what's also critical as
your voice. And that's why I
think these former so important
to do across the state your
voice in this conversation is
very very important we have to
bring together all stakeholders
if we really want to address
this is it so that includes you
I want to thank you all for
being here every student
deserves. A safe learning
environment. And we can stop of
nothing short than that. So
that's what our goal is that's
what the aim is- thank you all
I just want to come give
welcoming remarks thank you for
having this UC Berkeley thank
you for posting it. Thank you
thank you so member wicks. What
to begin this conversation and-
they what they what they're
going to want to sit and listen
to you- wanna begin the
conversation with an expert who
we have with us today- I want
to welcome our special guest.
Dr Charles. H. F. Davis the
bird. Who is the chief strategy
officer of the use university
of southern California. Race in
equity center. He will be
providing us with an overview
of the work the center does
nationally around address
assessing campus climate. And
racial equity. Dr Charles Davis
thank you for being here with
us this evening and sharing
this information thank you.
Greetings madam chair. Members
of the select committee in all
those here in the audience
attending. Thank you for the
opportunity an invitation to
join you this evening to
discuss issues of campus racial
climate and our work in
relation to these issues at the
U. S. C. race and equity center.
The USA race in equity center
was established in twenty
seventeen at the university of
southern California. Primarily
is an interdisciplinary
research organization dedicated
to identifying racial
inequities. Prescribing
evidence based interventions
for the end of racial justice.
Center strength primarily lies
in its interdisciplinary which
brings together scholars and
researchers across various
fields and disciplines to
address issues of race and
racism within post secondary
institutions as well as broader
society. I currently have the
pleasure of serving as the
center's chief strategy officer
and director of research. In
which I support each of our
centers primary portfolios of
work to include assessment and
evaluation. To learn an
organizational development and
a global hiring. Today have
been asked to speak
specifically about our work in
assessing inequities in student
success and soon experience
because universities across the
nation with in the state. So
please accept this following
testimony is my best efforts to
do so. Earlier this year the
center published its fifty
state report card which
examined- academic year twenty
sixteen and twenty seventeen
access and equity indicators
for black undergraduates at
five hundred sixty four year
non specialized public post
secondary institutions in the
United States. Data were
driving to specific federal
sources the first the U. S.
census American community
survey. And secondly the US
department educations
integrated postsecondary
education data system. Using
these data the report
specifically assessed for
indicators racial
representation inter racial
gender equity completion equity
and black students to faculty
ratios. My representation
equity we were talking about-
determining the calculation of
difference between the percent
of black undergraduates at a
specific institution and the
percent of college age like
residents within the state.
With regard to gender equity we
were determining- through the
measures of enrollment gaps
between black undergraduate men
in black undergraduate women
relative to the overall
enrollment gaps of all women in
all men across racial and
ethnic groups. And institutions
with any particular state. With
about to completion accordion
we assess the differences
between the average six year
graduation rates for cohorts of
black undergraduate students
and for cohorts of
undergraduate students overall.
And for black students to
faculty ratios we determined-
the number of full time degree
seeking black undergraduates to
full time black instructional
faculty. Letter grades were
then calculated for each
indicator using a Quintel
distribution and what's the top
20% received a grade of a- the
remaining letter grades within
distributed evenly enforce and
20% increments. In addition to
warding letter grades for the
for equity indicators we
calculated an equity index
score for each institution that
was the equivalent of a grade
point average. And so it's
customary in the same fashion
we do here because in
universities. Encountering GPAs
we assign four points for in a
three for a bi to for a C. and
one for a day. Then averages
some of those indicator grades
to determine the index score.
In in to determine the state
and that's where we average the
sum of all institutional index
scores within a given state
calculated. The average equity
index score across all the five
hundred six public institutions
was two point zero two. No
campus aren't above a three
point five. And two hundred
housing overseas earned scores
below two point zero. And
institutional level you see San
Diego cal state Monterey Bay
cal state Fresno and UC
riverside were all located
amongst the top thirty five
individual institutions
nationally. With index for the
three point oh or better. The
state of California receiving
the next work two point four
six ranking it third amongst
all states in the nation.
However it to be sure such
ratings and rankings are wholly
contextual in relation to all
institutions assess. Disturbing
grades in quintiles Evelyn
required us to provide Asian
bees to some institutions that
actually performed poorly.
Relatively not as bad as the
remaining three fifths of
institutions in the whole study.
Differently our calculations as
he would say and students
sometimes appreciate is graded
on a curve. It's going grading
on a curve we attempted to make
clear that scores not
necessarily reflect or indicate
blacks in equity. For example
while the score two point four
six ranks California most the
highest performing in our
study. It's a reflects a C.
average black student equity in
their forty man significan
improves the made especially at
the remaining twenty seven
institutions. It's going below
two point seven five.
Additionally in a separate
report published by the center
that examine racial inequities
among black male student
athletes and see double a
division one power five
conferences. Which cal Berkeley
UCLA. And USC and Stanford were
included. What the report
evidence is that there
disparities in graduation rates
months black student athletes
which were abysmally low in all
cases except for Stanford.
Which were objectively high. I
find this particular important
to notice California recently
led the nation in deciding to
allow athletes to earn income
off of their likeness to
endorsements which is most
relevant to those in revenue
generating sports such as
football and men's basketball
what's the overwhelming
majority are comprised of black
men. It's to evidence in a
report. In which definition
institutions and roll black
male. Students at a rate equal
to or less than 3% of all
students. Well black men
comprise. Between thirty and
56% of the football and
basketball teams. In this is
reported by both said he's only
measure specific quantifiable
outcomes with which each report
was concerned. And although
they may reflect in some way.
The environment within which
black students live work and
learn the do not
comprehensively assess factors
most commonly associated with
campus racial climate. And
therefore for their in
different assessments are
essential to understanding the
relation between post secondary
environments their social
context is to experiences and
for this reason the center
together. With a panel of more
than fifty nationally
recognized experts on campus
racism survey methodologies and
college students develop the
national assessment for Klay
just campus climates. Unlike
other assessments the neck
takes intentionally narrow
approach to isolate racism of
the phenomena under study.
Based on our previous centers
decade of work on campus
climate we learn that broader
recesses often fail to provide
the necessary death to dress in
one of the nation's most
intractable problems. What is
more racism routinely is pushed
further into the margins by and
areas subsumed under the
contested and under specified
banner of diversity equity
inclusion. In the wake of the
rising tide of white supremacy
on college university campuses
and elsewhere within broader
society. We thought it
important to restrict our
assessment to the deep study of
race and racism. The survey
administered to all students
within a particular-
participating college
university. And the necklace is
perspectives on the ways
students perceive experience
the campus racial climate. More
specifically the knack is
designed to not address whether
racism is present in an
institution. In fact it is
designed to help institutions
identified the various ways
that institutional structural
interpersonal racism manifests.
The service comprised of sixty
five separate items across five
primary content areas the five
being battering affirmation
racial learning and literacy.
Across racial engagement
encounters with racial stress
appraisals of institutional
commitment and the impact of
external environments.
Currently he's content area
scored using racially
disaggregated metrics from
select blocks a survey items
with any particular domain and
their assigned ratings one
through four. And again we
thought this important because
often we have the data reported
it often just opposes white
students with everyone else and
so we thought it wasn't too
just aggravates we can
understand the specific
experiences of individualized
racial ethnic groups. During
the twenty eighteen twenty
nineteen academic year which is
our pilot your for the knack we
successfully administer the
survey nationally to more than
two hundred thousand students.
Including those it eight two
year and four year post
secondary institutions within
the state of which the
university of southern
California in those other
institutions here today are
represented. While attending
national St report of our data
is still being developed. I can
share with you that our
findings were consistent with
decades of research on campus
racial climate. Secular between
white students and students of
color broadly were found in
every single content area some
of which were more pronounced
between specific racial ethnic
groups and their white peers
for example our findings among
the California schools
routinely show gaps in cross
racial engagement that is that
students of color generally
were both more likely and more
open to engaging in
conversations about race with
white students than white
students were with their
students of color peers. This
finding indicates a need for
college universities to
consider interventions that
better. Excuse me. Requires and
to consider intervention the
better prepare white students
to not only voluntarily engage
across racial difference. What
to do so around issues of race
and racism in ways to
communicate and understanding
of their own privileged
positions within institutions
and society. Primarily governed
by powerful white people and
white supremacist ideologies.
Further our findings indicate
in under represent
underestimation of racial
minority students encounters
with racism by white students.
In particular yes something put
forward by many white students
within our assessment tools
that racially- CD raising my
north high students experience
instances of racism in the
classroom on campus. I rates
far lower than self reported by
them. These about a few
examples including the
reporting bar data from our
participating institutions.
Each of which is provided an
individual and relatively
confidential report. However I
want to focus for a moment
again on the external factors
associated with campus climate.
Forge relatively little
research has been conducted. In
the current socio political
climate. Which campus season
which is relatively dormant in
comparison to those in years
during Emily following the
election of Donald trump's the
presidency of the United
States. In this is a campus
racial violence of spite.
According to a forthcoming
study led by size Stokes who
joins me today is a research
associate with our center. A
multi year data analysis shows
dramatic increases in races
verbal and physical attacks on
college campuses. Specifically
this study examines over three
hundred fifty reports from
higher education new sites
between twenty thirteen and
twenty eighteen. Between twenty
thirteen to twenty fifteen
specifically an annual average
of twenty seven incidents
occurred. However we sixteen
alone a high in nineteen
incidents were reported.
Yielding a 3100% increase the
year prior. Overall nearly two
with. Of all reported incidents
were violence against black
students specifically at white
universities. Additionally two
hundred nineteen of three
hundred fifty acts of racial
violence were patch waited by
white people. With another one
hundred twenty perpetrators
being on now. It's still. Soon
lives are not limited to this
the college university campuses
and often traverse the
boundaries between town and
gown this post new questions
regarding the safety a racing
mind or t<c.cyan> students in</c>
trying to communities. Within
which post secondary
institutions are situated. The
comedian out look any further
for cases been within the state.
There is the presence of
recruitment fire's post about
white supremacist groups which
California leads. Or the anti
semitic anti black and if I can
look at goes along dorm walls
around the frequent presence is
of hate speech disguises the
democratic debate of ideas. But
these phenomena in fact are
present across the UC CSU a
community college system. And
the name graver circumstances.
What students are rendered
immediately vulnerable the
moment they leave campus. In
ways entirely more violent than
those reported on campus. For
example that is considered
Humboldt state university here
in northern California. That
there. They're in city of
Arcadia on April fifteenth.
Twenty seventeen David is I
lost in a black student at
humble state was stabbed to
death and all. After being
stabbed a size friend fellow
student ID channel begin
administering CPR while white
people at the scene reported
citing said and I quote. I wish
the **** does die. I really
hope that **** dies. More
police officers and other
emergency medical personnel
arrived at the scene it is
reported that they failed to
administer lifesaving aid their
different relator wasn't
dysfunction at officers
further. To detain and question
any witnesses. A twenty four
year old white man from
McKinley bill city nearby was
later arrested and indicted but
the case was later dismissed by
humble county Superior Court
judge. What is more the six.
Thousand dollar payment to the
national police foundation to
review a PT's conduct in the
case is yet to deliver its
report. On the incident more
than two years later. And all
the while. Charmaine Lawson.
Decides whether has been left
without answers and without her
son. And to be completely sure.
Justice is not the furniture
report or civil settlement for
grieving mother. Justice it's
just I Los and still being here.
And so with that I again would
like to thank you for the time.
Madam chair and your the rest
my time for any questions. I
think you in your report you
indicated that. That the you
know you have a time frame of
the accident so- some folks
would say that it started
twenty sixteen others will say
it started much earlier. What's
your assessment. I in terms of
the races incident happening
yes- my assessment is that
these things have and will
continue to happen we know that
from the integration of.
Secular institutions in the
south up until today- that
campus racial violence is a
very real part of what people
are experiencing. And so
although we may have seen a
spike in those incidents that
are reported that does not mean
that they weren't happening in
the same volume earlier on- but
in fact we have. Can isn't by
which we can report these
things when they do take place-
we also have press who in their
sensationalized. To review of
the way the world works also
want to be able to- monetize
some of the cliques by
reporting on these incidents
more frequently. Have you seen
any campus that's been very
successful in dealing with it
in my experience I have not. I
think many campuses are always
already ill prepared to
respond. Any particular
moments. And that is being
evidence so simply by students
who are taking a part of our
survey. Them often say that if
there is ever a response it is
only when tragedy strikes or
crisis arises. But there is not
really preventive measures are
being taken into account. I'm
even more so- that means to
show leaders are falling back
on policies that do not account
for the way the campus racism
functions. To say that they
cannot intervene. They must
yield to. What they perceived
to be. A constitutional right.
Again to engage in what is
considered free speech although
it takes me to deeply impacted
campus racial climate. Thank
you very much thank you there
may be some questions or
comments after. At the end one
of thank you with at this time
we're going to call our first
panel for work this is a- the
students perspective on the
panel. I want to introduce our
first pound each presenter will
have seven minutes of testimony
will come forward. And at the
east end of each panel we will
allow ten minutes. For
questions from me and I and
maybe Mrs Skinner she peers-
and at the close of second
panel public comments will be
taken from the audience so
there will be an opportunity.
For public comment so will be
after the two panels. This is
our student panel. That we have
here today. And I'm not sure if
you do you guys have a
preference in in water art is
the order that we have here
sufficient. Okay. First student
is going to be a long road
Garcia the vice president of
external affairs and San
Francisco state. Of followed by
a studio khn who is the move
some students association west-
she's a transfer student who
attends sambar Dino valley
college and now. Tend UC
Berkeley- the next to will be
Dominic Williams the former
chair of racial justice now
USA- the fourth June will be
marines summons the eternal
chair of police oversight here
a AS you see. And lastly we're
truly Natalie's. Ahmed mu how
did. Who is the president of UC
Berkeley's in double A. C. P.
chapter welcome and we look
forward to hearing from you.
Who's our timer. Okay here's a
signs okay but time thank you
so everyone knows. Who are
timers thank you very much will
begin. With the laundry. The
song okay yes- hello everyone
I'm a long dress cable Garcia
I'm the vice president external
affairs first issued students
at San Francisco state and also
a director for the cal state
student association I'm
currently thirty year at Sam
Cisco state double majoring in
political science and Reyes
resistance studies. I would
like to give my knowledge mint
the every call State University
is diverse and different in its
own way we operate in different
locations Sir different types
of students over all under the
same system the CSU system a
part of the mission for public
universities including the CSU
is to support a learning
environment that promotes and
protects- through through.
Exchange of diverse ideas I Sam
Cisco state we've established
division of equity income
inclusion in twenty seventeen
within the vision we've
established a black unity
center in Asian American
Pacific Islander student
services center a dream
resource center. And starting
next year hopefully will. Have
a lot an accident center and a
pride center. Hopefully act. As
a state is one of the first
public universities who's hired
staff to focus on student
interface- programming they've
higher sausages of us the
Jewish student life
coordinator. And Serena he's a
little grew as the Muslims to
real life coordinator. They
have ensured proper anti bias
ally ship in training to be
hold for students faculty and
staff which I have personally
taken and- he did an- as the
state continues to. Help
students feel comfortable and
safe and which I have of. Well
as well armed with all the
services and trainings they
have been offering even though
there's a lot of amazing
programming and services being
offered for students in the CSU
system. There's still some
racial biases and hateful
incidents happening in our
institutions. This summer us of
state campus there is anti
semitic messaging in our
bathrooms as far as promoting
xenophobia. I get students and
faculty members- last semester
we've had several students who
identified of white supremacy
king ethnic studies courses
questioning- faculty of.
Walking around faculty and
students. I cal state Fullerton
recently they've dealt with the
uses of the way Edward on
flyers from student
organizations on campus. I
called a police low recently
had students host a gathering
the end illegal aliens versus
cowboys I constantly ask myself
why racial Hippel incidents are
still continuing or campuses.
Are universities need to be
trying hard to ensure students
are feeling safe and to hold
students staff and faculty
accountable. For the racial and
hateful incident that we
participate in. I'm deeply
concerned for students safety
in the twenty twenty
presidential elections during
presidential late elections he
crimes usually go up in twenty
seventeen the department of
justice have reported that ten
point 5% of. He crimes occurred
on college campuses being a
public university we're bound
to be in an open campus as well
in an open campus insurers
freedom of speech is Matt. Will
also ensures the outside groups
can come onto our campus
improvement he'd speech against
our students. We the university
in all stakeholders such as a
so should students and
academics and as of
universities you to provide
safe spaces for students and
have open forms to have these
conversations. I know so
citizens on my campus is the
official voice of students but
we have students are in
privileged positions. That need
to be reaching out to students
and holding administrators
accountable when he for racial
bias incidents occur. Instead
of using or cities being
reactive when incidents
occurred we need to be more
proactive in prevent these
incidents from happening in the
first place. I would like to
think assembly member Weber for
competing the panel and for
hearing on students
perspectives on racial. And
hateful bias incidents thank
you thank you. Hello sorry
guys. Are good evening and
thank you doctor Weber members
of the subcommittee for hosting
this important hearing. And to
the Berkeley student
organizations for helping to
put this event together my name
is audio con. And I'm a senior
transfer at UC Berkeley I a
formerly attended summer and
you know Valley college- and
during my time but that
Berkeley and SPV see I've held
various leadership roles in an
effort to uplift. Marginalized
communities like my own Intel
crazy for and campus
environments for all students.
However today I'm here as a
student leader from MSE west
aye nonprofit organization that
works with thousands of Muslim
students across- various
campuses to provide. Programs
resources into is just support
the social- emotional and
spiritual needs of more some
students across California- we
believe that creating a- safe
campus environment for all
students meets having
culturally competent staff an
admin. Working together with
community to develop structural
solutions to the many
challenges students are
experiencing. Today I am here
to talk about the often
overlooked perspective which is
that of the Muslim community.
We are one of the most diverse
communities with no singular
racial ethnic or identity
background that can you know
cap the intersections of our
experiences. However are some
of the most common challenges
that we face. Come from us some
of the student perspectives
which- students experiences at
the UC CSU in committee college
level. Basically lack any data
on our community- most public
institutions have very little
data. Are specific to the most
some identity or when there are
attempts to capture this
information it is usually. Only
used aren't Africa south Asian
groups which will is a step
forward excludes significant
portions of most of student
community that clued. But not
limited to black là next
southeast Asian and white most
some students- because of this
lack of data as a west partner.
Institutions on social policy
and understanding to conduct an
initial large skilled research
study on. I'm going to some
sort of population that
analyzes the population's needs
holistically- this past January
you we collected data from over
five hundred students and this.
Search basically found in
various forms of
discrimination- in whether it
was political community
engagement identity wise- there
was a lot of discrimination
that our students are facing
and I wanted to share some of
that with you guys today-
according to the research that
we did we found that 63% of
Muslim student respondents-
reported facing some level of
religious discrimination in the
past year. And fourteen point
2% of the students have
reported facing religious
discrimination on campus from
professors in the past year
with woman reporting a higher
rate than men- I personally
experienced many such incidents
including my very first
semester summer do you know
Valley college right. A
mandatory cool history course
where. In the first week of
class my professor presented
very Islamophobic talking
points to the entire class- he
claimed that Muslims forced
women to dress a certain way
that Muslims abused women that
we worshipped. A moon god and
we refuse to move forward. The
rest of the world and we were
stuck in medieval and backwards
mentality. As the first week
like very early during my first
week of college. How do not
experience it was completely
horrifying and quite honestly
it was extremely intimidating
because here is somebody that
is supposed to be- providing us
with. Information and yet he is
turned down my identity and who
I am as a person. And to watch
my peers take that in as fast
as truth is honestly very
hurtful and- eventually led to
me. Doing extremely bottom not
class I ended up not being able
to engage with my peers or my
professor. Because this was
extremely triggering to past
experiences that I had of
verbal and physical abuse
because of you know some of the
big rhetoric. And so you know
not having any adequate support
or resources from the campus to
navigate the situation I
ultimately feel that course-
again you know I had a similar
experience was a of course.
World. My professor use a text
book by in a slump phobic Asama
phobic non most some who
basically portrayed Asama as
that backwards religion and
just. You know pretty much
toward on my identity as a
Muslim and created a very
hostile environment for myself
especially when my peers are
taking all this information in
and seeing it as fact and that
is how they are engaging with
me after you know seeing that
information- according to some
of the- research study that we
did. You know a lot of our
students. Reported that even
with administration they are
unable to report these issues
or that they don't feel like
reporting these issues will be
affected to our administration
our survey found that 10% of
the respondents who. Reported
facing religious discrimination
on campus are actually face
that from administration as
well so- which is extremely
high number to face the disk to
Fuhrman ministration
considering most students don't
usually interact with
administration- campus climate
is affected by a number of
factors. But most significantly
it also includes our peers and
being out of school like UC
Berkeley you all are Sir found
that 31% of most in college and
in California reported facing
religious discrimination from
their peers on their call
campuses other at Berkeley you
know we see that with. When our
hello here's our you know
holding. Out. In guest speakers
who are actually renowned
renowned. When students in our
classroom discussions are
echoing the dangerous rhetoric
that vilify just Pham or 181%
of most of students who have
been approached. To exponent
splaine controversial topics
about it. This indicates
collectively- instead these
incidents collectively
contribute to a hostile climate
that impacts all aspects of our
lives including our ability to
learn and thrive on campus- in
addition to the over
discrimination on campus is one
of the most pressing issues
faced by the most of students
on campus recently has been the
surge of surveillance programs.
Primarily impacting most
someone box to dance in the
past few years have been-
counter violent extremism
programs being implemented on
college campuses across
California- CVS the department
of homeland security program
that began in two thousand and
eleven. To address rider
station in America by targeting
the Muslim community through a
national security framework
that firms Muslims especially
youth has been prone to
radicalization. Initially CV
programs took the form of
grants for DHS to target cities
across the nation meant to
distribute community
organizations. To minority most
some communities. And report
the information back to the
federal government sick of time
tonight I cannot go into
further the full scope of CVS
and its impact on the most and
community brought for the
purpose of this hearing. I
would like to highlight that
recently we have seen TV
programs surfacing on campuses
across California including. UC
Berkeley UCLA UC Irvine casting
summoned you know and more.
These often take place in the
shape of professors research on
course works on campuses. With
one enforcement and federal
agencies to create programs and
produce research on terrorism
counter by. Counter terrorism
and violent extremism that
targets does that they believe
are the biggest risk. Being
Muslims. These types of
programs create paranoia and
distrust and hostile
environments for those were the
targets of surveillance. And
have long lasting impacts on
already vulnerable communities
the most of community has been
subject to unwarranted.
Surveillance for decades
especially post nine eleven and
the uptake of CV programs
throughout the community and
now on campuses in particularly
concerning for the safety of
most well being of my some
students I am only touch on the
surface of this. Here on the
explanation and impact of these
programs and we would be
interested in following up
conversations with folks from
the legislature. And from-
campus system discuss the topic
and impact it has on the well
being of students- all in all I
would just like to say that the
most of students you know are
facing a variety of challenges-
and we would love to. Have you
know further discussion on
these are topics and we would
love to share the MSA west
report with both the campus
community as well as the
legislature. To discuss these
topics further and to follow up
and have for the conversation
on these- and with that I would
like to thank the- committee
chair for hope. Having us I
think they are you thank you.
Our next speaker is the dumbest
Dominic. So I thank chairman
Weber and the committee for
having the speech you all today
in having your hearing at UC
Berkeley- the worst you see for
black students according to the
U. S. he said he release this
year and according to black
students for a while now. My
name is Dominique Williams and
I am a graduating senior at cal
and I'm the first in my family
to go to college. I've been
intimately involved in
California higher education
policy for the last four years
as an advocate in our campuses
student government. Meeting
with state legislators to
communicate soon issues
directly to the years of
Sacramento. Also when I think
doctor Weber for passing AB
three ninety to the California
act to save lives. We needed
that. Additionally I have
served- roles here on campus as
our black city you use
community program director and
also spearheaded the creation.
Of a statewide campaign. Named
racial justice now which is
housing operated under the
university of California
student association. I've
actually spoken on the select
committee before as a witness
to other structural issues that
California California tie
ducation system has and I'm
grateful to be here today. I
believe it is incredibly
symbolic to have this hearing
here given that given what we
know about the black experience
a cow. I can appreciate the
messes this hearing will have
not only. To the administration
at this campus but also to the
rest of the UC administration
including our outgoing and
incoming you see president's.
Students have known for a while
now is that despite the common
descriptor of a progressive
campus in the most progressive
city in the world. Students of
color tend to suffer a UC
Berkeley. The twenty fourteen
campus climate report for which
we are all reflecting on here
today highlighted that students
of color and black students
especially. Felt alienated in
uncomfortable on all of our UC
campuses. What's more is that
many black staff members in
faculty felt the same way.
That's understandable
considering that many of our
black staff members are
unionized and often told their
labor isn't as valuable as it
should be by are you see
ministration. But it is surely.
That report sparked H. were
sparked by a trail of over
instances of discrimination on
our campuses. Revealed that our
campuses have a problem. In
that problem has arguably
gotten worse. I say that
because there are at less under
represented minorities and
black students on our campus is
here now then in twenty
fourteen. And the students have
not felt their sentiments being
translated and reverberated by
the administration. That's not
to say that our our
administration has made no
effort UC Berkeley has rolled
out the African American
initiative features cautious
were small courts of about two
dozen students. Administration
me regularly with the black
student union and other
affinity groups on campus
strides have been made and I
think our vice chancellor an
assistant vice chancellor Oscar
to money muted well. For
helping our student leaders.
But these efforts are not felt
by large swaths of our
communities because
unfortunately. The conditions
they are experiencing at
Berkeley have not changed.
Black students are still facing
instances of discrimination on
our campuses they are still
facing police discrimination
and brutality despite you see
B. D. receiving more training
than any other department in
the country. At least that's
what they say. And soon still
feel like they don't belong.
I'll give us all an example.
Following the passage of
proposition two oh nine which
banned affirmative action
across the state the UC
implemented what are called
student academic preparation in
educational partnerships or say
pet programs to address the
real income education and
racial gaps that have played
our education institutions.
These programs have been
heralded by the state
legislature as the primary
means of promoting diversity at
the UC but year after year
since two thousand five they
receive pay cut after pay cut
and there funding in real
dollars has decreased coupled
with rising housing costs. And
skyrocketing tuition. Black
students and students of color
because of the systemic
marginalization that are cancer
mentioned earlier in our
society are too often also our
lowest income students and are
hit hardest by the lack of
resources. We definitely feel
like we don't belong if we
can't afford to go here. Almost
starve ourselves in order to
afford our books. Another
example that's a little more
intimate. You see PT please use
the PT that's had a terrible
police officer on its payroll
for decades name officer Shauna
Ramos bass number seventy six.
People Noah. This officer has
terrorize members of our
community both on and off
campus his claim to fame being
when he arrested and
confiscated the wallets of a
Latino hot dog vendor at a cal
football game. One black
student in particular has been
literally harass by this
officer over six times for
fraud in the soon to not be a
student. He was so bad that he
became a symbol for us of just
how by bad cops can be and how
much they can get away with.
And finally after years of
complaints. Petitions meetings
and investigations. UC Berkeley
led arenas retire. Retired he
wasn't fired he wasn't brought
to justice he was let he left
with the retirement plan and
could serve at any other police
department if you wanted to. At
offices symbolize how much we
really meant to this university.
Fortunately my colleague marine
will delve more into our police
relations but adding that to a
lack of resources black face a
UCLA in twenty thirteen deport
them all signs at UC San Diego
and you see more said in twenty
seventeen and a disaster over
free speech week last year.
Black students especially have
been reminded that we are not
welcome. And that's probably
part of the story that U. S. C.
report black students face a
graduation gap of 16% compared
to the campus as a whole black
shoes complete Berkeley at a
rate that's 15% lower than the
rest of the campus and this by
making up over 6% of the
California population. Black
students are only one point 9%
of this campus. We are
underserved in under taught not
just at Berkeley by the way
that all of our UC campuses.
That USC report validated will
black students have been
feeling for decades. Like to
have a special then on our
campus called black Wednesday.
Every Wednesday all of the all
the black students gather for
the Golden Bear cafe to exist
with one another to meet each
other. And just enjoy each
other's company. It's a space
re created for ourselves when
we didn't have one a place to
listen to music and see each
other on campus. Because it's
been so where to see ourselves
anywhere else in our classrooms
in our discussions when our
dorm rooms. For decades student
leaders that organizes of and
have had a harder and harder
time to yield a sizeable crowd
AB like Wednesday. We felt our
numbers dwindle every year soon
as dropped out after two years
our brothers and sisters are
falling in between the car the
cracks. Crushed by the lack of
support the receiving by this
campus. For so long are
concerned- receipt then brush
away. With administrative as
ministration anticipating. That
the graduation of student
leaders can induce and then
some spell of a short term
memory loss. Recycling four
year old ideas and
conversations and sending it
back years of progress. So for
all of us in the room a
reminder. Proposition two one
nine devastated the numbers of
black Latin American native
American Pacific Islander in
middle eastern students on our
campuses. We have asked for our
campus in the UC administration
directly to take a stand of
opposition to proposition two
or nine. And work with you
number of are the members of
our state legislature to recall
the proposition. We ask you
know. Choose a color and black
students to work with the
students of color black in
black students to overturn
proposition two or nine so that
our students can receive the
resources they need. To be
taught equitably. An additional
asked we have is to better
support are safe at programs.
Free ongoing funding that
restores and maintains state
support tied to inflation
undergrads an undergraduate
population growth. You see
students and staff alike have
been squeezed of resources for
over a decade and I diversity
has suffered as a result.
Culture senator recruitment
centers are utilizing student
labor like their full time
employees and they're not
getting paid for it. In order
to make up the loss of the
state induce. Are soon as well
on campus and those who may one
day envision themselves here
need to feel like they can
belong here. These are a few
ways we can start and I welcome
my colleagues to share their
testimony as and also offer
their recommendations for you
all thank you. Thank you. Thank
you very much. Maureen Simmons.
Thank you first I want to say
thank you so much to you
assembly member Dr Shirley
Weber for. Grazing in our
campus today. And it means so
very much to not only UC
Berkeley but- I am certain that
time your presence and
recommendations I'm will be
felt throughout this see
issues- cece's. And the UC
system. My name is Maureen
Simmons and- this is my last
semester at UC Berkeley. It's
so important for me today to-
to have this meeting. As my
colleague Dominic Williams
pointed out it was roughly
about a year ago that I sat in
a room. And with members of our
black student leaders and we
discussed that U. S. the
article. I was my first
semester here on the campus of
UC Berkeley and as a first
generation older student. I was
heartbroken. At just the fact
that students felt someone
welcomed- at first and want to
believe it and then. Very
quickly I soon began to realize
that this was a space that was
quite hostile to people that
look like me. I am the timing
of relevance of this is so very
important and I don't want that
to be to go unnoticed. The
procedure I am so to the roles
that I have on the campus one
of them is the internal terror
police oversight and I want to
talk about specific examples of
the relationships between black
students on this campus and you
see P. D. N. how all that
interplay's with the racial
tensions on the campus my role
as the internal chair of police
oversight is to provide
recommendations to the
community leaders as well as
to- are relevant stakeholders
which would include our
chancellor's office. I have had
the opportunity to meet with
our cancer- on an occasion last
semester and I want to talk
about to loop of the incidents
that led to the conversations
all of two thousand eighteen as
I said I'm members of the S.
you see- spearheaded by myself
and members of other black
student organizations how to
conversation with the
chancellor's office following
an incident where it was
determined that you see PD use
excessive force in response to
a campus incident for faculty
members were staging a peaceful
protest- when video surfaced of
the police and county Mister
David Cole could be seen
surrounded. Their protesters as
UC PD. Made contact with the
men of simply arrested him.
Another incident is earlier
this year my office was
involved in an incident what
was brought to my attention
that one of our African
American female students. Who
is currently enrolled suffered
an encounter with UC PD that
resulted in her arrest. That
student suffered severe trauma
and mental anguish and is still
traumatized to this day. I
placed several phone calls to
UC PD as is required by my
office. I was able to set up a
meeting with our chief of
police Margot Bennett and also
lieutenant Julie Williams who
has worked and closely with my
office and the a as you see on
similar incidents. You're not
meeting I was really. Taken
aback by one of the comments
that. Chief Bennett said in an
in essence not a direct quote
but she talked about her lack
of understanding of where this
rage racial animosity comes
from in the fact that as a
white. Female that she just
really simply does not
understand and cannot really
empathize with black people but
that she hopes to get there one
day. To lead our police
department and not understand
what the- implications of that
sort of mindset is was
completely as far as I was
concerned unacceptable. I am
following that meeting and
conversation- I'm- lieutenant
Williams said in the
conversation something else
that was really startling and
it speaks to the racial
tensions on this campus. He
talked about the fact that the
student who was only guilty of
having a taser and when she
tried to give the taser over to
the police officer. There was a
struggle that ensued just
because they said she reached
for the taser. And they tackled
her arrested her and the
response that I ask was there
any other way to handle that
what I was told by lieutenant
Williams is. In essence she's
lucky that we didn't shoot her
and if we would have shot her
it would have been. Killed. The
fact that are UC PD- for some
of you it's the first time
you're hearing that but- for
the fact that are you see PD
was here and supposed to be a
part of our campus community
and team. To ensure that
students not only feel safe
here but welcome here what have
the attitude that they would
think that it's okay to say
that we would shoot a student.
Over a taser is startling when
I met with chancellor Chris I
am price I asked that was there
any way that we can begin to
manage our relationships
between that the UC PD and
students. I talked about the
fact that white students. I am
large don't have the same types
of incidences. Of the things
that I asked for I'm that we
thought was very reasonable was
the fact that we wanted police
vehicles Berkeley is a very
heavily militarized. On campus
when you come on to our campus
the first thing that you see if
you enter from the MLK side our
police vehicles. Right behind
an adjacent to those police
vehicles is our Fannie Lou
Hamer center with our black
student resource center I asked
can we move the police vehicles
because it's traumatizing that
black students bill that
they're in circled in in case.
By police and I was told that
we could do that. To date that
has not happened another thing
that we ask during that meeting
this if we could have more
sensitivity training for police
officers so that when they
engage with black students in
particular. Given the climate
that we have in this country
it's not just on this campus on
this country that we need to
begin to be able to deal better
we were told that we would get
that. To date we have not done
that finally we asked if we
could have the police not look
like numbers of swat because
this is a college. As they
should be part of the allege
culture we're talking about a
reasonable. Request to date
they still look like swapped.
Black students have continued
to raise and finally in my last
few comments I want to piggy
back on what my colleague
Dominic Williams said. In
regards to proposition two oh
nine. Just a few months ago
when the members of the UC yes
they met and we begin to talk
about the strategic efforts
that we could take to begin to
deal with the issues that
students face in the UC system.
I thought. We have to repeal
two oh nine to get anything
done. That is an effort that we
are leading as students we are
asking the- administration to
join in that effort to repeal
proposition two oh nine. And as
student we believe that that
will create a more harmonious
impressed I'm- more harmonious
culture for us. And on UC
system CSU systems as well as
the season with that I think
you. Thank you our our final
speaker for the day. Good
evening this thing. Good
evening give it good evening
distinguished members of the
state assembly cancer crest
administrators members of the
community I would like to for
start up a recognizing this
land and its indigenous people
members of the who Chen alone
the tribe we must recognize
this sad sad history of this
land and the genocide that
occurred. For the university to
be built. Secondly I want to
thank doctor Weber in her
office for the time they have
spent. In the development of
this event their commitment to
stern activism and up lifting
the margin and up lifting the
voices of marginalized
communities. Lastly I would
like to recognize. The students
of this community who have
contributed to development of
this event. And those who allow
their passions to drive their
commitment into carrying out
the work. Thank you to marine.
Dominic on the Tara Varsha.
Lucky a million and local. As
we speak about the injustices
and hardships faced by students
of color and the institution of
higher education. I want to
encourage folks to be cognizant
of the reasons for why we are
here more specifically I want
people to reflect on why it has
been five years. Since students
have see very to little no
change and how they are being
met. I acknowledge that the few
changes that have taken place
in the past five years.
Certainly I Berkeley have been
born out of black student
activism. Not university
officials are region's. For
example the Fannie Lou hammer
black resource center the
African American initiative and
the two but mental health
therapist we have today our our
fruits of the labor of blacks
in activism in twenty fifteen.
And on were today. As a
sophomore stern here cap. My
experiences have been nothing
short of Dominic statement I
still to this day remember in
ways I was welcome. To this
campus as a black Muslim
identifying male. I remember
being met was there's a
confusion irrational fear an
outcast ostracized by peers and
their families alike. As I
moved into the residence hall
on day one. It is and has been
a commonality among our blocks
the population for blacks it is
to not feel as welcomed on this
campus as our non black peers
slash counterparts. It is too
often wear black students are
faced with the cost of policing
by. Of their rights and a and
access to this camp is and it
is known practice for you see
PD to ideas and be and us to
feel isolated by you see
employees. I will never forget
the moment during my first
semester. Mid term season I was
leaving Moffit library around
two AM. And stop I used to be
the officer asked a series of
questions about my whereabouts
with the assumption that I was
not a student here. After
coming to the conclusion that I
am indeed a student here cal.
He let me go and I returned
home safe. When we talk about
safety who can afford. For
students such as myself who
carry them narrative a multiple
marginalize identities and is
predominant white and east
Asian American space we know
these encounters are very much
a part of our everyday lives
both on and off campus. So the
question becomes what is safety
and what is that look like for
black people. When the curry
CPD chief of the UC Santa Cruz
is a state police officer who
pepper sprayed innocent
students during a demonstration
at UC Davis. And when you see
PT officers at UC Santa Barbara
filed a lawsuit against the CPD
for discrimination and
harassment the workplace simply
for trying to be better cops.
We know that you see P. D. as
an institution is problematic.
In fact a diversity projects
spearheaded by the chances
office. Found that students of
color one UC Berkeley's
administration to and I quote.
Consider entry experiences of
policing as a key dimension. Of
campus belonging and address
the needs and concerns reported
by students. Who have
experience negative encounters
with the police directly and
you're care sleep. Especially
black students LGBT because
LGBT Q. aye plus students.
Nontraditional students. And
students from underrepresented
minority groups. I asked over
twenty black students to
describe their feelings about
cal with one word. Dangerous
dramatic safe hopeless on heard
depressive anxious terrorizing
marginalizing useless
heartbreaking oppressive
community questionable tiring
over burdening and
uncomfortable. These are just
some of their responses for the
built in the room I would like
you all to be aware of them and
for the students in the room
look no further than the person
sitting next to you because
many the participants are
sitting right here with us.
Today. These feelings translate
the poor and the performance
levels. Putting back in Boston
is at a disadvantage in
comparison to their non. Like
invested appears. Not to
mention the fact that many of
these students double jobs
families and activities beyond
the classroom. We know when
students feel safe and welcomed
they perform better and in
return promote a healthier
campus climate. However when
students come to the campus
with their outside experiences
of having to live in a world of
racism. Misogyny Islamophobia
xterra coupled with their
experiences within student body
here I cal hopelessness becomes
the reality. This is in
addition to the fact that black
and white next the this is in
addition to the lack of black
in the annex staff faculty and
administrators. Take a look at
our campus in your cabin and
what you'll find is a
predominant white ministration
that is tasked. With
inclusivity of all people on
campus. I noticed of
conversation to have but as
university as human beings we
must be aware. Of how this
campus and many others within
the state of California.
Disproportionately affect. And
continue to marginalize
students of color. Our tax
dollars go to the same
institutions that her and
traumatize our youth. And it's
only right that we ask the
necessary questions to hold
administration accountable. So
what does that look like
legislatively I propose that
the state legislators allocate
more funny to the you see that
goes to support one is programs
and resources for black about
communities on our campus. This
a good staff and faculty and
should expense each campus
throughout the state of
California. This here I
Berkeley are are black
committee has a- African
Americans to develop office.
And the Fannie Lou black cam
resource center which I'll
mention again with the center
that was fought for not given
by the Universitarios I suggest
that the state legislators
focus on intensely supporting
marginalized groups within our
campus community. And think of
ways on how they can for the
support the state ability of
them. I'd advise the campus
administration actively listen
to the grievances of students
of color. And one express their
needs. And actually work with
them to solve these problems
with agency. Berkeley needs to
and should recognize that there
is a crisis within the ways in
which black students engage
with this campus. As stated in
the US the report. While the
study did not cover approve any
new information what it did do.
Was validate the sentiments
from the community and raise
awareness and conversation
around the bodies. Of black
students in higher education
and within the context of this
campus. If people are serious
about tackling the campus
climate issues. See the UC
Berkeley undergraduates the
diversity project campus
experience working group's
recommendations that I cited
earlier. I want to thank
members of the community for
the resilience I am and
dedication to persevere despite
the legacies of prop two nine
and racism as these
institutions were not
originally built for us I
continue to thrive off that
notion. You see Burke as
institution oppose systematic
oppression it continues to
March I students of color.
Thank you to the members of the
assembly for coming out and
administration administration
personal here with us today.
Thank you to me as the rest of
the world was assisted by
center for equity inclusion and
the chief of staff to authored
by who is the vice has of
equity inclusion for being
administrators who we can trust
and work closely with black
about students. They get a
ticket Jackson who is director
of aftermarket to develop
office who has countless number
of times been there for us and
care through the better
students and finally I want to
thank you to my ancestors
welcome before me I sacrifice.
Their lives for me to be here
today doing this work. Thank
you. Want to thank all of our
student panelists. Even as much
to chew on it that think about.
If I had to ask each one of you
to give me just one suggestion
that you think would truly make
a difference on this campus and
all campuses. Just one. What
would it be and I'll start at
the far end- for that one that
you think would really make a
difference. I don't know
there's a lot but if you have a
no one is to say aha yes.
Definitely decreasing policing
on college campuses the what
decreasing policing on college
campuses what is that me so-
recently and my campus
particularly we've increased-
policing so having more police
officers on campus which I
personally do not feel safe
knowing that they're on every
corner- patrolling and- keeping
us safe for emergencies in
reality- they don't do that.
The just. Create more fear
within- a lot of black and
brown students- especially
around the college of ethnic
studies which mostly a lot of
our black and brown students
are located- there mostly
patrolling that area more
aggressively. So okay would
would would would down. What
would and because often times
the only can one way and all of
us have that. What would- what
would create. A safer or
feeling of a safer environment
that a police officer. Because
normally in our culture that
talks about safety so what
would what would it look like-
would be hiring a more
counselors a social workers
would be- you know I I'm not
sure. That's why I'm asking you
what would it look like if we
were to talk about. Of
decreasing the number of police
officers on campus. In order to
make you feel safe what would
we increase. Definitely more
counselors I know at my school
in particular there's one
counselor for every thirteen
thousand students- which is a
lack of counseling for a lot of
our black and brown full. On
our campus so definitely
increasing more counselors.
Alright what would you have as
as the number one thing keeping
because I was amazed at some of
the things you step faculty
were doing which I consider to
be- as a former faculty are
still faculty merit is on
campus I would consider to be
just one of the worst things
that could ever happen would be
for a faculty it'd give
misinformation but also to
create an environment where
other students who feel. That
they have the right to have a
negative attitude toward
someone as I me. We have a
greater responsibility than
that so as a faculty member I
find it very difficult what do
you think would be the one
thing that that could happen
that could. On this campus as
well as a community college
what December Dino at the
community college. What would
you think would be important to
as one thing that would that
you think would really make a
difference for is for Islamic
students- so. I think honestly
when you look at the data from
UC Berkeley specifically. Most
of the vast majority over 85%
of our faculty and staff are
white. So that just having that
you know that they are going to
be partnering with
organizations that are harmful.
To you know whether it's black
students whether it's most some
students whether it's not next
units- do used. It if we don't
have diverse faculty and staff
they will never understand the
issues that we are talking
about they will never
understand. The daily you know
issues that we deal with those
students the fact that the UC
system has made no effort in
trying to. Hire more staff that
is more diverse and more
actually knowledgeable on these
issues the fact that. I was so
excited to take. Okay as a
language class because my
family is from focus on and
would do is our- national
language. I was excited to take
that course until I realized
the professors the white male
from Texas. Okay soul and this
is no disrespect to you know
however much you might have
study that language or anything
like that but when he's
referencing Bollywood in India.
To try to teach the national
language of August on is very.
Just I don't I don't I mean
yeah it's very uncomfortable
and the fact that you know. The
fact that we don't have diverse
faculty the fact that our
faculty are working with
programs like C. V. E. the fact
that we have to ask are you
know so. School in
administration not to partner
with organizations that help
ice or other organizations our
students are continuing to be
targeted not just within the
classroom but you've been
outside the classroom when
these professors. Are working
with organizations that don't
see us as human. Thank you
Dominic would you would be the
one thing that I'm gonna ask us
all to be brief because I know
we've got another panel to
hear- what would be the one
thing you think what. Would
help. Refill pop tune. Sounds
good okay what about you Marin.
Well I want to take the other
side of woods idea was saying
that we need to make a greater
effort to recruit and retain
blacks across the issues the
seasons and the UC system and
the reason for that is because
if we don't have students today
we won't have a diverse faculty
for tomorrow we're trying to
pull faculty out of a- that is
limited to begin with and so
we've got a began to make our
pool- better and that will take
a- systemic changes. Over a
long period of time I need to
be a trend actively engage in
aye second- what my colleague
says is without repeal two oh
nine we already know we're
gonna keep hearing that we are
limited we can't do it so hill
told nine but we need to have
more- you know a real effort I
have twenty years in human
resources I don't know how it
is that we keep saying to all
nine is the issue. I hired
black full all the time and it
wasn't discriminatory but- here
we are. Among. Two things arm
our campus loves money and they
left making promises so I would
ask that the state legislator
in conjunction with lieutenant
governor. To work with the UC
regents body to have a plan.
That actually- has some and
goals with the time frame. That
when our campus makes promises
that they keep them and ask
these- problems they're being
audited. And our campuses are
actively being- investigated
ease maybe two years three
years four years. To make sure
that they're making a promises
because right now- the only
organizations on our campus
they're doing good work like
bridges. Which recoup some
attended by students and other
under percent minority groups
our house in a closet- you know
for the former student union.
And they were supposed to have
an actual center- into in
nineteen were here right now we
don't have that. So it be nice
for the state government's
their auditing and start
wondering where's the money
going to. Sounds good sounds
great. Want to thank all of
you- just so you know that- two
oh nine is not that far from
our conversation in the
capital. At least my
conversation so- we will be
making decisions about that.
Fairly soon. But thank you very
much for your your your. Thank
you we're going to have our-
are put second panel which is
you see. See issue and
community colleges. The talk
about the progress an update of
on- dial on recommendations
from the twenty fourteen campus
climate recommendations and
responses to the rise. In
racial hate incidents- it's
quite a challenge on these
campuses we know to try to meet
those needs and to bring the
change that so central. To all
of our campuses- in some of
made more progress than others
and some. Makes progress
forward and then someone of the
gets pulled back- it's not easy
to- try to bring change on
campus that they most of you
realize that. So we have with
us today we have- the second
panel. In the panel provides us
with an update on the progress
as I say that they've made. On
the twenty fourteen campus
climate recommendations. Of
representing the university of
California we have Lee is how a
monk. Who is the associate vice
provost for the UC office of
the president. And Oscar do
bond junior who's vice chance
of equity inclusion of year UC
Berkeley. From the C. issue we
have- Mrs Lee for a Friedman
who is the associate vice
chancellor and deputy general
counsel- see issue of the issue
and doctor. Reginald Blaylock
who's in from presidential
associate for student affairs
partnerships in senior
strategist. I'm cal poly
Pomona- lastly we have
representing the communicative
we have doctor Cynthia all of
all who is seek you out from
the California community
colleges chancellors. Chief
student services officers and
vice president of student
services at Pasadena City
College. So it's great to have
you all here- and we look.
Forward to hearing you
beginning with a- our first
person on the panel Liz lemon.
Thank you doctor Weber good
evening. My name is Liz hollow
mall and I'm the associate vice
provost for diversity
engagement. The universe the
California office of the
president. On behalf of the UC
president I want to thank you
for your continued interest
doctor Weber in advocacy.
Improving the campus climate
for all of our students faculty
and staff. I also want to thank
the students speakers for
sharing their perspectives. You
will experience as a
recommendations. We can all
action that acts of heat
intolerance discrimination or
bias whether directed at
individual or group have long
term effects on the believe our
students to learn and thrive.
For faculty teach effectively
conduct world class research
and of our staff to work and
contribute productively. It is
our responsibility both at the
system level one of the
campuses to do whatever we can
to improve our campus climate.
As president Nepal tunnel said
in two thousand fourteen.
Respect and inclusion requires
a constant attention Militar
used to community every student
every professor every
administrator every staff
member everybody every day. UC
campuses develop action plans
in response to our two thousand
thirteen system wide campus
climate survey. But those
action plans could not
anticipate the signet Vance but
a fundamentally shifted the
nature of discourse in colleges
and universities across the
nation. These events of course
include the two thousand
sixteen presidential election
the rise of the all right. For
your actions to rescind doc
grow in anti immigrant policies
outside groups expressing their
view points directly on UC
campuses. So if asked whether
it's been harder for
universities to quote unquote
manage campus climate I would
say absolutely yes. With that
in mind I will now summarize so
the most recent system wide
efforts to prove campus climate.
Those efforts are intended to
complement and support efforts
of the campus level some of
which will be described by my
colleague UC Berkeley vice
chancellor Oscar newborn. First
starting in spring two thousand
seventeen UC campuses were the
scene of a number of bands.
Incidences or demonstrations
their chartered Ted
marginalized groups or
individuals. Resulted in campus
unrest and negatively affecting
campus climate as you will
recall the events in UC's
responses to them. Destructive
local and national media
attention. To guide officials
from the campus is a managing
the best of this kind we
develop tools and training that
help caps in ministry- is
police chiefs diversity
officers campus council lawyers
indeed of students. To
coordinate and maintain
consistency with respect to the
university's position on free
speech. Time place and manner
roles protest management
protocols responses. To acts of
hate or tolerance this includes.
To prepare for in marriage
major incidences like the kind
I described. Since this time of
the campuses are far better
equipped and prepared to both
respond to these kinds of
events while also taking
ongoing proactive steps to
maintain a positive campus
climate. A second example is
the UC policing task force. Two
thousand eighteen present
president appall tunnel.
Created a prison presidential
task force to examine the
investigative practices. In the
use of force related policies
and training of the UC police
departments. This was in an
effort to strengthen the
departments practices. And
their relationships and
interactions with the community.
Some key task force
recommendations included. The
creation of a uniform complaint
process at all you see two
locations including an intake
system for reporting
complaints. Officer misconduct
and the post is incidents
review process. The continued
development of policy and
training on the use of force
including de escalation
techniques and effective
communication. And as we will
hear more from from the vice
chancellor it upon the creation
of advisory boards on every
campus include faculty staff
and student representatives. As
of this date the advisory
boards have been formed at all
the campuses the complaint
intake system is the early
stages of I. T. development. A
third example is in the area of
anti virus training. As you
know doctor Weber the two
thousand eighteen budget act
included a one time
appropriation of one point two
million dollars. For two year
pilot program to provide
antibodies training for
ministers faculty staff and
student leaders at you see an
ad CSU. Joint UC workgroup
issued a request for proposals.
Select your just communities of
central coast to deliver the
pilot program. These training
will reach sixteen hundred UC
and CSU faculty student leaders
senior administrators in start
trainers I fourteen okay a four
locations across the state.
Training will begin in January
twenty twenty and will conclude
with train the trainer
workshops July twenty twenty.
Through these trainings
participants will examine
they're all personal by cities
and then they will also learn
how they can influence behavior
decision making in academia.
The walls in about in practice
the Marvel used to practical
strategies to this rock bias.
Thank you again doctor Weber
for you continue commitment and
advocacy on these issues. Are
you see we are trying to pry
the tools the methods the
people to respond to acts of
intolerance by hate. At the
same time. Keeping constant
attention every day by
everybody consisting respectful
campus climate. For all of our
students back being staff. I
will do my best to answer any
questions you might have thank
you. This a double. Thank you
doctor ever for inviting me to
speak on this important panel
on behalf of UC Berkeley for
thought like to say like to
thank the students for once
again affirming how they are
always on the right two sides
of the issues so I really
appreciate that- also like to
thank Ahmed for- acknowledging
the land were in- that's
something that we should
always. Be in our conscience
around not just being gassed in
the land of the- wake me Aloni
but also- to understand that
the work that we do should
always be in honor of the
histories of. The or people who
are here. The issue of campus
climate as it relates to campus
safety protocols and procedures
the prevailing and persistent
topic on the nursing the
California campus. At Berkeley.
A clear indication that we are
not where we need to be on this
deeply important issue. In
order to get there we must
first articulate what that
there is. That there is to be a
place where institutional
excellence is founded on
principles of belonging where
the full humanity of each and
every member of our campus
community is recognized and
respected. And invited to print
transform the academic
enterprise the research the
student experience university
structures. Practices and more
in a process of co creation.
But before we can get there we
must acknowledge the tent
challenges and histories that
have pave the road to the
president. One of enormous
achievements as well as one of
systemic marginalization. Like
most institutions. And
structures in this nation UC
Berkeley have was established
as the White serving
institution or is it because
existence. And over its
existing has promoted whiteness
at the cultural norms and
standards in which its
institutional excellence is
couch. These historical and
experience of facts are
antithetical to our principles
of community and are valuing of
diversity. We must be
intentional and making
institutional and cultural
shift that support belonging
beyond the norm in support of
non white groups specifically
and marginalized targeted
communities in general. My
remarks will therefore examine
the campus climate and campus
experience data of under
represented a marginalized
groups through this lance. As
my colleague Liz Holly
misstated the entire UC system
took a UC campus climate survey
awhile back. At UC Berkeley in
nineteen in two thousand
thirteen our data indicated the
following. 25% of respondents
reported that they personally
experience exclusionary
behavior ranging from
intimidation isolation and
exclusion to hostility. A
higher percentage of ethnic and
racial under presented groups
especially African Americans
reported experiencing
exclusionary behavior based on
the racial identity as compared
to non under represented
minorities. A higher percentage
AB T. Q. plus and persons with
disabilities reported
experiencing exclusionary
behavior at their to other
groups. A higher percentage of
staff respondents reported
experiencing exclusionary
behavior based on their
position status as compared to
faculty. UC Berkeley took
immediate action to think
through the best ways to
address our specific campus
climate issues here represent
some north now know where the
actions. The African American
initiative lunch in two
thousand and fifteen with six
major objectives. To raise
twenty million dollars in
scholarship fund for African
American students. To improve
the recruitment and yield of
African American students and
other under represented at that
minorities. To boost the social
personal and academic support
provided to current and future
African American students. To
improve the classroom campus
experiences to increase African
American staff representation
in Berkeley senior management
and to improve the campus
experience frac for after the
making staff and faculty. In
part in partnership with black
students you see Burke. Any Lou
Hamer black resource center in
two thousand seventeen which
centers on the needs of black
students and is open to
everyone. This resource center
acts as a hub for ballistic
services to black students
ranging from academic social
and psychological belonging. In
two thousand seventeen the
disability strategy team
analyze concerns brought to our
leadership by our campus
community with disabilities I
submitted a report Jennifer
crisis with five
recommendations. The goals of
the stables dreaded abilities
tragedy team where to move
beyond compliance and close
persisting caps that keep
members of the disabled
community from experiencing the
campus equitably. As a result
in two thousand eighteen we
hired a five oh four eighty a
compliance officer and created
an offices of this work we
need. Further in our next. To
establish at the table
community cultural center. UC
Berkeley for gender equity
resource that in collaboration
with campus and non campus
partners continues to be a home
for the aged LGBT Q. plus
community and support other
wellness and to provide tools
to educate the campus community
for example a set of videos was
produced to broaden our
understanding about the
importance of using preferred
gender pronouns. Dead to
acknowledge the full humanity
of a LGBT Q. plus and
marginalized communities.
Effectively serve California in
the nation we are working on a
path to becoming an Hispanic
serving institution. This year
the chancellor appointed a task
force to develop a blueprint
that will not only clarify and
effective plan for our region
recruitment. Of
underrepresented minority
students including the land
it's community within the prop
two oh nine framework but also
to. Transform the campus
experience through a framework
of belonging we're by white
superiority is no longer the-
norm and the experience and
contributions of our- color to
margin immunities are elevated.
Chancellor Chris the nav and
initiative in which faculty
cluster hiring will be pursued
around five areas a scholarship
that will support the campus.
The campus is commitment to
faculty diversity. Through a
campus wide all proposals for
the cluster hiring a faculty
across the stem fields social
sciences and arts and me and
he's- has been submitted. This
in its initiative is in
addition to very successful
effort funded through the state
supported initiative on faculty
diversity. In two thousand
seventeen. And the chancellor
engage the entire campus
community to examine policy the
procedures that both protect
free speech and maintain our
principles of community.
Throughout the many activities
panels talks and forums that
were held hate speech at
psychological state the rose to
the top of the conversation for
marginalized communities. The
university provides information
on the stop hate website on how
to this report I hate and buys
incident as well as how to
obtain support and- support
services. Hate instances eighty
incidences are described in the
following categories
intimidation bullying physical
violence hate speech graffiti
but realism Hossa clam make
climate. Bias incident and
expression of bias. Our current
ethics point data show that we
had thirty eight reported on
campus on campus hate
incidences. To reported hate
crimes one camp security and
one report of harassment during
the two thousand seventeen
reporting year. And into the in.
Eighteen thirty reported on K.
incidences to hate. Also.
Appropriate support services
such as counseling
psychological services and the-
for support an intervention in
addition to other identity
based resource centers that may
be helpful on the prevention
side we have the bears that
care program which is located
within the center for. A for
support and intervention. This
year the UC UC Berkeley large
its local my experience survey
examining the campus climate-
through it the experiences of
the campus community we are
currently in the process of
analyzing these look these
local data. To come up with a
set of interventions to a best
any gaps in experience for the
campus community here are some
preliminary findings regarding.
Regarding campus expertise
concerning police- policing on
campus. Approximately three
quarters of respondents rated
you see put you see PT
positively. Minority Maynard
ties groups consistently rated
you see PD lower than majority
types peers. Between half and
two thirds of African American
and trans gender non conforming
a gender non conforming
respondents rated you see P. D.
negative. These results a line
with broader national finding
of perception of police.
Initiated by student activism
following incidents of police
violence naturally and on and
on or near UC campuses and
consistent with these
preliminary results. The UC why
presidential task force on
university wide policing with
convene Erica mena that each
campus that was an independent
advisory board to work with his
leadership the campus community
and its police department in
identifying and addressing
issues Bob mean the safety and
quietly quality of life- of
students staff and faculty. I
personally think that this is
the number one issue on campus
around campus climate. When
asistir someone up quickly okay
on okay- UC Berkeley
established the it's in the pen
and write report. On police
accountability and community
safety which held its first
meeting in mid September I'm
happy to discuss that more
further. Does that we share and
appreciate your interest and
care for this particular topic
on behalf of students faculty
and staff we understand that.
The type of change that we are
discussing takes time resources
and shared accountability among
campus administrators campus
community and the general
public thank you. Our will and
it would miss Friedman. Yes
thank you doctor web review.
Attention it is all of the I
see the. My name your Friedman
and I service the associate
vice chancellor and deputy
general counsel for the
California State University.
Thank you so much for inviting
me to speak today before your
select committee campus climate
and I'd also really like to
thank the students who spoke so
eloquently- earlier- I'm going
to update you on the steps of
the CSU. Campuses have taken
and continue to take to improve
campus I met since the
committee's hearings in two
thousand fourteen and its
subsequent report I feel like I
have a lot of good news to
report but when I think about
what the student said I realize
that we really still have a lot
more work to do. A my chance
office colleagues in academic
and student affairs and equity
and Percy regret their unable
to be here today- they're
conducting a three days system
wide training for campus
administrators on California
state. Percy processes for
responding to and investigating
discrimination and harassment
complaint so I guess that's a
good reason that they're not
here. My testimony today will
include nation that my
colleagues have provided to me.
And I hope that I'll be able to
answer any follow up questions
but if not we'd be happy to
provide further information
writing at your request. CS use
for an eighty thousand students
make up the most ethnically
economically and academically
diverse student body in the
nation. The CSU provides more
than half of all undergraduate
degrees earned by California's
Latino African American and
native American students.
Nearly one third of CSU
students are the first in their
family to attend college.
Because of this the CSU is
committed and determined to
create a welcoming environment
for all members of the campus
community. We have increased
our efforts on student touch
points through a student
centers and other affinity
groups to improve a sense of
belonging for students of all
backgrounds. Student affairs
staff student life and
development staff academic
counselors including staff from
E. O. P. foster youth programs
and dream centers are in
constant dialogue with our
students so that our students
experiences can inform our
programming and trainings and
so that we can continue to
improve our campus climate for
all. Our programming is varied
in substance and modality
includes diversity awareness
and campus orientation sessions
multi cultural welcome
receptions for newly enrolled
students and work with their
student leadership. On
approaches that they believe
would best serve their fellow
students. Campus forums to
discuss campus climate online
training for faculty and
students and also campus
climate surveys which more than
half of our can campus does
have conducted in the last five
years. The goal of orientation
is to help new students become
familiar with their campus this
is their new home. To have them
interact with and meet new
people and to build a network
of friends and support to learn
about resources and to gain
knowledge of university
policies and procedures. Many
of our campuses are
experimenting with approaches
that involve peer to peer
discussions for example at San
Jose state the chief diversity
officer combines presentations
with small group discussions
led by students. And finds that
this approach allows for more
intimate and substantive
discussion of complex issues
surrounding diversity and
identities of race ethnicity
class religion sexual
orientation gender identity and
immigration status. Each CSU
campus has at least one
cultural program club
organization or center on its
campus many have more.
Depending on such as each
campus has key staff overseeing
its efforts to ensure a safe
welcoming and inclusive
environment for all students.
Eighteen of our twenty three
campuses have opened dream
centers that provide a touch
point and support to
undocumented students and
allies. Even campuses that do
not have an actual center
provide support and have at
least one point of contact for
students. The CSU will use some
of the one time basic needs
funding in this year's budget
to create partnerships with
community and other external
organizations so is to increase
and leverage whenever possible
wraparound services available
to our students here are some
examples of our work. We're
developing ongoing partnerships
with community organizations
that have a tradition of
helping populations
experiencing basic needs and
security. We are connecting
students with community case
managers who have knowledge and
expertise in accessing safety
net resources at our counseling
centers we offer personal
counselling sessions to address
family and relationships sexual
identity suicide and other
psychological needs and our
counseling centers also offer
support groups focus on gender
cultural groups and sexuality.
The service delivery model is
extremely important to
empowering students to take
advantage of mental health
services. The committee's
report noted the importance of
dis aggregating certain data
emphasizing that providing
disaggregated data for the
fifty ethnic or national
origins that have in the past
been categories as one group.
Asian Pacific islanders will
help to demonstrate the
disparities that exist between
them. I am pleased to report
that since two thousand
eighteen we reported on such
dis aggregated data on our
system wide website. We're also
collecting data with respect to
LGBT Q. plus community- for
example the cal state apply
application and the student
self service portal. Invite
applicants and students to
provide information about their
sexual identity and sexual or
Asian. The chancellor's office
is also developing
modifications to our common
common management system to
help campuses implement the use
of preferred pronouns. As the
state of California and the CSU
have rebounded from the
recession we've also improved
our- the hiring of tenure track
faculty and it's the data shows
that it is more diverse but
there's still more work to be
done. I'm not gonna talk about
the anti bias trainings because
Liz has already described
those- and just in closing I
want to say that university
campuses our marketplace of
ideas and it's important that
our community sustain a healthy
appetite for debate. And even
for disagreement. The CSU does
not and cannot restrict who was
invited to speak on our
campuses based on the content
of their speech. Provided that
the speech is lawful and I have
to tell you that hate speech is
lawful. Not something we
welcome but it's not prohibited
by law. Controversial speakers
present many challenges that
drain economic and human
resources on our campuses this
is important work and we must
safeguard the safety and rights
of our entire community to be
heard and to dissent even when
speech causes pain and anger.
We also work hard to teach our
students and other of our
community that the best way to
respond to speech with which we
disagree. Is with more speech.
We owe it to our students to
lead by example and help them
learn how to speak and dissent
effectively. The university's
response to incidents of hate.
What happened. And whether the
incident involved more than
protected speech the rules can
seem very technical at
sometimes infuriating that
individuals are not held
accountable for expressing
before views that because a lot
of pain to members of our
community. We might not be able
to undertake formal discipline
but that does not stop us from
appropriately responding to
incidents to ensure and
maintain a safe environment
that demands compassion and
respect. Campus professionals
including bias response team
serve a very important role in
safeguarding our community
values provided they do not
create confusion about where to
report and how to seek
supportive measures.
Universities are microcosm of
the complex world in which we
live and we're deeply committed
to make imposes an inclusive
welcoming learning environment
that's a safe home for all of
our students we thank you for
your support during these
challenging times. Thank you.
Thank system is to play a lot.
A good evening ladies and
gentlemen. It is an honor to be
with you this evening. It is. A
deep personal privilege to be
here tonight. My freshman and
sophomore years in college back
to Weber was a faculty member
mine a professor of mine. This
is just three or four years ago
okay no are you. She she was
then. Teaching and training
nurturing developing growing.
And yes loving her students
then as she's doing the same is
for students and faculty and
staff and families and
communities now. So for me to
be here this evening it's
really quite amazing and
personal privilege of mine to
be here enjoying doctor Weber.
I also want to take a moment to
honor- our students from the C.
issue a launcher Garcia. To
come here to see that you drove
two hours to get here and
traffic is gonna drive I was a
good home tonight. To come here
represent four hundred and
eighty thousand students in the
largest university system in
America. We appreciate. Want to
work thank you for over
recognized her in honoring her
this evening. One take this
time to share with you a little
information about Cal Poly
Pomona homeowner Broncos. And
our campuses commitment to
diversity. A couple more sets
on the eastern edge of Los
Angeles county and what is the
neighboring county of San
Bernadino. The campus is a
little more than twenty six
thousand students. It's an
eighty year old institution.
And it is supported by about
twenty five hundred faculty and
staff. And the student body is
roughly one third Latino one
quarter Gen and 3% black. The
campus has been designated is
already been designated as a
Hispanic serving institution.
And is in the top twenty five
colleges awarding baccalaureate
degrees to Hispanics. Recently
the Hispanic business magazine
also a lot of the university's
ability to help Hispanic
graduates. Couple of homeowners
commitment to fostering
inclusion at our institution
start from the lead ship would
dock disarray coldly. As the
six president of our campus
present cold is the first woman
to be named Presidente cal poly
Pomona. She is ushered in a new
era of strategic leadership for
the campus establishing a
vision for cal poly Pomona as a
model for an inclusive party
technic university that
inspires creativity. Discover
en innovation embraces local
and global challenges and
transforms lives in fact in of
the third one thousand three
hundred and sixty three
universities listed. On the
most recent social mobility
index cal poly Pomona's third
in the nation. That means
moving students from poverty to
middle class within five years
after graduation. Kampala
promote is the most diverse
polytechnic university in
America. And we are committed
to valuing and the lived
experiences of our multi ethnic
student body. This begins
immediately for students even
before they formally start
their academic journey account
Polly. All incoming students.
Including first time freshman
transfer participate in a
mandatory orientation that
prioritizes diversity training.
Such training into discussions
about their diverse identities
and how these may shake their
experiences at the institution.
Wants to join our campus the
university fosters connections
to our six cultural centers the
play a critical role in
empowering them towards success
through engagement. Leadership
development and diversity in
Richmond. The cultural centers
include the African Americans
to resource center the Asian
Pacific Islander center this
season each Chavez center for
higher education. The native
American student center the
pride center and the women's
resource center. Additionally
in two thousand sixteen we
launched the Broncos dreamers
resource center. All new
frankly are required to also
participate in orientation
training program which includes
diversity and inclusion
training as essential
components of introduction to
our campus community. This fall
Kampala homeowner is also
hosting to campus conversations
for its students discussing our
collective efforts to foster
inclusion in our university
that is meant to engage our
student body. The first in
conversation was held on
October twenty third at
students and of course and
November twenty first will be
hosting our next- student
campus conversations. The
intent is to provide support of
space for students to dialogue
about their experiences and
recommend ways to continually
improve our campus climate. In
addition to these are pleased
to share this evening other
critical steps the universe is
taking the foster inclusivity
Kalpana Pomona. Recent campus
measures include a standing
university inclusive excellence
council the will develop and
recommend proactive strategies
for strengthening our inclusive
environment. An administrative
campus climate response team to
respond to campus climate
related concerns in an
integrated timely and
transparent way. We recognize
at all is it is may not rise to
being unlawful the discipline
may be awful. So how do we
respond the bill's timely
transparently inclusive. We're
going campus complain policies
and procedures to ensure
clarity clarity for reporting
pathways processes and
transparency. Do an
institutional membership all
faculty members of university
have access now to resources
and support through the
national center for faculty
development and diversity. And
it's in our will have a forty
team- group of faculty staff
and students going through
training as well that's a nice
step for the UCC issue. All of
us working together and then
we've also launching into city
inclusivity theme speaker
series cosponsored by academic
affairs and student affairs so
we're bringing in speakers not
just the speaker released about
conversations and what happens
after we've heard the speech.
And we are. We wants the
researchers is a critical steps
are campus to fill three new
leadership roles at the campus
dedicated to diversity and
inclusion. Are the first of the
presidential associate for
equity diversity campus climate
who report directly to the
president serve as a member of
the president's cabinet.
Secondly we want to search for
the executive director of
student inclusion and
belonging. Reporting to the
vice president for student
affairs with a secondary
reporting line to the
presidential associate. And
third we are want to search for
the faculty diversity out reach
recruiter. Charter working with
academic affairs in the
colleges departments on
extending our outreach efforts
to increase awareness of the
excellence. Of count Poly
Pomona. And expand our
diversity of our candidates. I
can see that exists four
minutes left. So I want to
simply say that we are in the
work we are in the space we are
doing the working with the
commitment which students with
faculty staff and our alumni
and thank you again dark to
where it is a real pleasure to
be with you to see it's always
good to see Richard thank you.
A doctor Libya hi everyone my
name is doctor Cynthia- levo as
mentioned I represent the
California community college
system the largest system of
higher education in the world I
represent community college
students and one hundred and
fifteen community colleges as
well as the faculty staff and
administration- from the
chancellor's office I service
the president of the chief
student services officer
association and I'm of the vice
president of student services
at Pasadena City College I want
to say thank you to the
students Irene- as an
undergraduate students in
nineteen eighty five order.
Mystery Xin again. Proposition
one eighty seven to nine into
to see. It was a little-
awakening. And I was really
proud to hear you speak up on
behalf of yourself and your
your student your fellow
students. I also want to say
thank you to Reggie- my sister
attended San Diego State
University and I called Reggie
and say Hey can you look out
for my sis. And he did and you
know that's what we want for
all of you for all of our
students across the state we
want our students to feel
comfortable to feel safe and to
feel like they have a for
media. A family that's looking
out for them and that make sure
they succeed and so I'm here to
mention some of the efforts
taken up by the California
community college system. In
twenty fourteen we begin
funding what is called student
equity throughout the one
hundred and fifteen community
colleges. Every college
received an allocation in order
to make changes to our
practices to dismantle
predominately white institution
characteristics. And I'll I'll
mention at the chief student
services officer level we
welcome to that with open arms
for example last year we hosted
a conference and Dr Sean Harper
was our keynote speaker. This
year we have doctor G. look
good and doctors here brown
McNair her new book is called
from equity talk to act you
walk. And we look forward to
that. I work at Pasadena City
College and a month ago we were
featured in an article online
in political magazine. And we
were featured for our work in
racial equity specifically- we
closed racial equity gaps for
Latino Latina and let the next
students by ten percentage
points in less than four years.
How did we do that. We
implemented an implicit bias
training in our equal
employment opportunity training
which is mandatory for anybody
who wants to serve on a hiring
committee. Instead of doing
legalese and death by power
point from a legal perspective
for compliance purposes only.
We used it as an opportunity to
help people understand and
unpacked their own unconscious
bias when they're going through
applications and identifying
candidates to hire. In doing so
we've hired 15% more African
American and Latin X. faculty
on our campus. Additionally we
implemented new faculty aye.
Your long new faculty seminar
which all new faculty
participate in and it's based
on cultural competence cultural
relevance and cultural humility
in the classroom. We partnered
with doctor a stellar and
Simone and over four hundred of
our faculty staff and
administrators on campus
participated. In learning
equity mind this we developed
an equity data dashboard for
our college than anybody in the
public can see you can identify
our racial equity gaps down to
the course of all. In doing so
we also it stirred three racial
campus climate surveys one that
was mentioned at the beginning
our session today by Dr Charles
Davis that was developed by Dr
Sean Harper. The national
assessment for collegiate
campus climate second we
administered a survey that was
developed by two faculty
members at San Diego State
University doctors look word
and Frank Harris the community
college success measure.
Finally we administered the
higher education labor city
survey and the head survey
provided us with more insight
what do we do with the data we
allowed it to inform our
professional development plans.
Are hiring plans and to
essentially inform what
students need from us on our
campus to feel a sense of
belonging. I believe that we
can continue to close our
racial equity gaps by
dismantling practices that were
not designed for our students
in the first place. And it is
very possible to continue
moving the needle on racial
equity thank you very much
thank you. I thank all of you
for your- presentations-
obviously our campuses have
been. Engaged very busy in in
addressing these issues
obviously at different levels.
Of June- and I know our time is
up basically but I wanted to
make sure those in the audience
had an opportunity to make a
statement- but- just a couple
of things that- that I will I
would say and you don't have to
respond any ninety we have to
respond to today but- over the
last five years using a lot of
activities that have occurred-
you know a lot of program
development a lot of resources
put into it- efforts to hire a
different individuals. Up I
assume that in this process
there's also an assessment of
the effectiveness of will be
doing a and I say that because
I just had a an audit report
today that came out of
concerning. Local control
funding for me one of the main
things was no is not effort
sensing within our done is the
fact that we have lots of
activity. Of lots of programs
lots of goals and objectives
and yet we don't stop and say
that is ineffective. Let's not
do it again this is effective
let's do more of it- and I
think that's that's that's
because when I when I go to
hear a lot of activity. And I
would encourage I know it's
hard these programs going but
with. As an object system for
you to be a certain period of
time without with what you're
doing and then be honest in the
in assessing of which one of
these actually **** which one a
light. Would actually works to
accomplish these goals I think
would be helpful in. In
determining how you spend the
future dollars or future. First
so the question becomes you
know with the accountability
for the programs that are
there. Accountability for
faculty for of changing
behavior in a faculty- are we
talking about if you did
utilizing. That information as
a part of assessment and
evaluation of faculty determine
tenure promotion. Those kinds
of things- you know I mean
where are we in terms of the
seriousness of it because we
can do a lot of programs. But
until we begin to crack through
the real difficult task which
is making sure that. Not only
we say what we want but we
enforce what we want. We
demonstrate that and I think
that was some of the comments
with the students here- they
don't necessarily feel see the
demonstration of it- especially
if they've got. A police
officer whose hard over and
over and over again in the
fact. Who continues teach over
over over again and I've been a
personal committees will people
have love people because they
both books. But yet the
students comments were
absolutely damaging and
horrible that they were saying
screaming through the
valuations and these. Are
people some of our students who
got aids I had a in a class.
I'm and as we kept saying that
inner Bennett and the
conversation was. She was he
did the best book in
anthropology this year. Okay
but the students are saying
he's horrible he's terrible you
know don't put you back in the
classroom again and we can't do
it because our standards didn't
really factory and their needs
it factored into the
institutions. Desire to have
greater ratings for whatever
who knows grants and so forth
and so on self I think you know
beginning to ask the question
okay when. We've got these we
obviously have these issues you
know that of the year what we
do is a system. Are the but
those are hard questions that
have to be passed in their
hearts things to implement. You
know I'm not naive to believe
it that when you start crack in
it. Professor tenure and
promotion it should be dig into
the heart of the institution-
which may be cold in itself but
none the less is the it's at
the heart of the institution.
So I hope that we get a chance
to have a some conversation
like that I would love to see
what you're doing in terms of-
accountability. And what and
how far was going to get with
that with regard to that so I
really appreciate all of the
work that you're doing in the
evaluation is the year. But I
given opportunity and what I
would encourage each one of
you- if that particular things
that you think would be helpful
to others that you make sure
that our staff gets those
things in terms of. Doing
because we. Do keep all that
mature. Will generate always
general. The I will one of the
few committees that. As an
assessment. Of our of things if
you could probably get. Of the
men the past. A lot of those
things do lead to legislation.
And that's what we want to make
sure that if the things we can
do. To support- encourage- I
know we did some things before
with faculty diversity and try
to make sure that was that was
being done. All and we've we've
done some funding in that area.
So that it target said in and
helps in some way- that would
be I think extremely important.
For us to know that that is
that that's something that
would be helpful- we've often
talked about a system system
wide assessment. Of like we do-
with- what is a separate when
trading everybody has to take
that. We have yet to in a
including. Players we have yet.
The same kind of thing on
racial issues. In terms of
training across the system I
know when I was chairman
department state. At the take I
don't know how many hours of.
On the internet every. Every
every. We don't have that with
regards to racial. Situations
which says. That is important
as sexual harassment probably
sell- and I'm just. So we need
to look at that and maybe
that's- we need to. Start
thinking about. In terms of
making sure our faculty- and
administrators. That off their
minds. That they have to be a
conscious of that. As well as
other kinds of biases that
exist- it just sends a message
that this is important it's
not. You know that. We can
invite up to have a comment to
make. Your comment is to be no
more than one. If you were a
time seven and someone close.
This to basically get a chance
to speak if you one of our
speakers opportunity talks of
the make you the latter one but
we want to make those if there
are any of you who would like
to have a one minute comment
please get in the line now so
we get a sense of who's coming
once the line is form would
never have full jumping in line
because it will be here all
night gives us a sense of how
many more minutes we have to do
so would invite you to come to
make your one minute statement-
and my staff you will will will
let you know when your time is
up. In terms of one minute
thank you. And please give us
your name in the campus that
you're from. Hi my name is on
the Charlie a aye ten UC
Berkeley here. And I'm the
black community endorsed
elected official in student
government. I wanted to touch
on some of the things that some
of my colleagues had said
earlier. First things first.
And most importantly. Repeal
prop two oh nine. It affects
not only the affirmative
action. Allowing students to
attend universities. But also
retention programs. And after
those students getting here.
Being able to have resources
and programs. Increase the
amount of diverse faculty
because anti by straining could
only go so far. As a black
woman in the computer science.
Department I'm not going to
learn from another black woman
before I graduate. And that is
the problem. Increase the
amount of students space and
social cultural centers.
Increase state funding to the
UC CSU NCC so they can better
support student programs. And
scholarships. And most and
finally. Demilitarize the U.
CPD. Across all UC campuses
because no school need the bomb
truck. No school need automatic
machinery that shrink to kill.
And bill you see should have
students. Who don't feel
comfortable. On campus to
learn. Thank you. Thank. You
you did in fifty five seconds
Hey EA. It's hard to follow my
name is a corner room here with
UC Berkeley I'm also ACC
senator. Elected Burke campus
wellness- and SB S. H. R.
belated issue the basic needs.
Are two things that I wanted to
highlight is that basic needs
is extremely important on
campus we have students. Who
are living in origins they
sleep in our libraries they're
eating out of trash cans living
in vehicles like this is a
reality on our campus. Have you
seen this exacerbated with
students of color particularly
black students on campus over
60% report being. Uprooted
secure homeless in the past
thirty days- in addition I want
to touch upon like SB essays
issues- we talk about this we
bring this to the forefront
very often but we don't
acknowledge the fact that a lot
of. Students who are impacted
or Cutie folks Marge I spoke.
And black identifying females
on this campus and a lot of the
times they get pushed out of
the system they're not given a
fair trial so also
acknowledging that. And just
pushing for more resources of
the students that I'm I'm I'm
also here to represent like the
pre health community. And I can
tell you the amount of like
students. Who have dropped out
from not. And we need like. We
need more black arm people in
academia and the only way to do
this to support them thank you
thank you. Hi my name is Amanda
hell I am a freshman at UC
Berkeley however today one to
talk about mostly the doctor
Reginald and- Mrs Freeman.
About cal pipe alone of since I
have a lot of friends to go
there and I in fact almost went
there- and their treatment of
blacks vans- recently there has
been a student action committee
formed- against the
mistreatment and micrographs
and that black students are
facing the classroom for
example some of them don't feel
welcome in residence halls- one
person. There professor called
different names depending on
how our hair is- like almost
rose or or Marley- other people
somebody wrote **** on a white
board in front of their dorm.
And just elevating their voices
and making sure that their
heard and that something is
being done to address this
issue because the street in a
black student. Especially at
somewhere like how point. Where
they're they're all these
initiatives is unacceptable.
Hello my name is Nathan my cell
I am a commissioner on
Berkeley's police review board-
I just read this also through
the UC Berkeley- often. Walk on
campus in my first week size
told her this was the number
one book universe in the world
the sundry times. I'm not sure
how you can be number one when
you were the worst for black
students. Everyone there said
it all the students sign for
that said it. We can more when
you walk around campus you off
to see the- benefits a- what if
in this generation weaker
cancer what if we just our
generation. We solve this great
big problem well let's ask the
same question when it comes to
racial equity in our campuses.
We can make big actions we can
do big change we can repeal
prop. Two oh nine we have to
think big thank you. Thank you.
October com thank you so much
for putting this on. Hearing
together obviously you've
continue to be a champion for
racial justice and equity at
the state. Thank you for that.
Are monies posh under the UC
student association the stock
number- and- I think I just
want to highlight as many of
our students said. Today public
comment panel. We have a lot of
issues to have to. Walk
through- you see had a twenty
fourteen serving their on
campus climate. And there were
a lot of issues that were
highlighted in that. We
continue to address these
issues because they have not
been fixed. Are we see those
effects still to the very very
real. And so we look forward to
working with you. On that the
area that we can especially one
of them being. Increasing
funding for equipment attention
centers. That does and really
good work was really fast up to
addressing. These issues and so
thank you for coming. Thank you.
Good evening doctor Weber thank
you so much for coming to UC
Berkeley tonight my name is
Marsha survey sure and I
service the external affairs
vice president of the east you
see UC Berkeley students
association. And I also service
the president of the UC
students association which
represents over two hundred
thousand undergraduates across
our nine campuses. And on
behalf of the UC students so
she should I want to reiterate
the importance of repealing
prop two oh nine and doing it
as soon. As possible students
have been calling on this for
years and years under
represented communities
marginalized communities on our
campuses have been fighting for
this for years. And years you
see stern association has
supported this probably longer
than I have been alive so I'm
calling on not just the
legislature to take an active
role in repealing this. But on
members of our university
leadership to call on this not
just supported not just
supporter quietly but actively
and loudly demanded because it
because it is a critical part.
Of solving our campus climate
crisis on our campuses thank
you so much thank you. We thank
all of you for coming today- I
wanna make sure we thank those
of students who from UC
Berkeley. And from other
campuses and staff for allowing
us to hold a- hearing to today
and I want to thank the
committee members. And the
panelists who provided their
testimony. Of sharing with us
updates and campus- efforts and
address the bias in the various
incidents that have occurred
on. Campus it's always a
painful to me I. Reflect back
on the fact that it's been.
Fifty three years since I
entered as a freshman at UCLA.
And of many of the fears and
concerns and feelings of
alienation and isolation. Was
also felt by me fifty three
years ago as a freshman. Of the
probably the student population
has an grown much since then.
In terms of the percentage and
so it is a- somewhat
disheartening after so many
years to. Still see that to on
our UC campuses- particularly-
we still have the- the issues
in the concerns of the year and
obviously. Going to address it.
When I have to dress because we
truly believe in it and fight
for it. A much more than of
give lip service in. Resources
and what have you to it it's
more than money- money helps of
anything but it's more than
money- is money is seldom
solves any problem with that.
When effort- to make it happen.
Someone to do that. Press of.
My appreciation all of your
audiences. For the hearing for
your input for your comments
and hopefully for your
continuing. Concern I have to
staff I thank my staff that's
around the room- who basically-
were- did this. List thank god
to me. Who is the chair of the-
of. The campus climate comedian
my office for me one of my
staff. I'll home nor cal Y.
Kaufman is here in the back
Laurie- Jekyll. For sure it is
here and is there anyone else
on the staff. Miles is here
miles is one of our student
interns working with us this
summer I want to thank those
student interns in the back
also with this last year-
Maureen and- was was one of our
student interns. Anyone else at
lucky- there's lucky sitting
there okay they were in a
student interns in my office
that. Gave us huh. Neon is here.
Okay she's gonna think what I
want to thank all of the
student interns we've we've
been very fortunate and blessed
to have students who want to
work in our office to come an
intern with us and- and it's a
really great experience one
think I met who was in my- my
young fellows. Program and
legislators in sac and San
Diego when he's in high school
so I see all of my children
scattered around the room- and
that's a great thing- we hope
we've given them some
experiences in our office in I
forgot. My oldest student. My
oldest student when I was
younger and he was younger too.
But I always take pride in the
fact that that my students to
hopefully get more than- just a
textbook learning but hopefully
get lessons for life. And
that's what's a really
important because you can
always access. Textbook
material nowadays on the
internet- and did and rather
quickly but it's hard to
access. The things that not to
learn with the things that you
feel. And that you know that
have a tendency to guide your
life- recent incidents in
campus crime to remind us that
the how much work is still to
be done. And how much we need
each one of us to do that work-
one students arrive on campus
they are welcome respected and
safe. Whatever their background
might be in is our hope that
that will always be. The in the
inside of the perspective that
these campus hearings that we
have. This is when I often make
Sacramento will but we have
inserted situations- or
celebrations. I remind them of
that the work that we do is
forever. We always think that
it'll in soon. That of that- as
soon as we accomplish this
everybody will be happy the
world will be better. And
everybody will love and respect
the body heals but I remind
everyone on the floor of the.
Assembly as well as those
throughout the cap. That.
Concept of racial inclusion
respect dignity those things
that are valuable. I like rare
flowers that have to be
constantly nurtured in water.
The love and attention. But
hatred. And discrimination. Is
a weed. I like most weeks it
grows best in that collect. And
so as soon as you turn your
back on it and think you've
accomplished something just
like in your own garden at
home. So as you put it in a
look so pretty and you don't
come back for a nother month.
You will discover the weed is
wrong with that picture care
without your nurturing without
your attention. And the work
becomes harder the second time
around. And so for all of us
this is the work. That has to
happen every day we have to be
conscious and sensitive to the
things that we say. That we see
that we do we have to put in
place policies that are
responsive to the needs. And as
those needs change we change
policies to response to it. If
that's the outcome we want. We
want a garden at is gorgeous
and beautiful and nurture and
inspiring. And it requires
constant attention. All the
time. If not we will have a
world as we sometimes feel we
have. Feel would be. Because we
all decided the work was
finished. And we didn't water
it again would impede into to
it. And now it has over grown
us and we're upset. The only
thing we can do is get in once
again. Are rooted out. And pay
attention thank you so very
much for coming